Hey everyone, how's it going? So excited
to be here with you guys and to share
more of some of the lessons about Alma
over the last eight months or so. All
right, first off, let me introduce you a
little bit more to what we're doing.
Now, it's our belief at Alma that eating
well shouldn't be hard. Good health
starts with a simple personalized
nutrition. For the longest time, it's
been super challenging to actually get a
good sense of how you're eating. And
despite all the different apps that are
out there on a personal level and from
talking to so many of my friends and
users throughout my journey in the
wearables and health and wellness space,
it's become just really obvious that the
equation is off, you know, in terms of
how much information you have to share
with these apps and so how little you
get back out. So it's our belief that it
shouldn't be this difficult. with AI, we
can finally solve this problem and build
something that's truly unique and a true
nutrition companion to help you kind of
strive towards your the best self. So,
let me tell you a little bit more about
what we're up to at Alma. So, we believe
that at Alma, there's three core pillars
to this new vision of an AI nutrition
companion. It really boils down to three
things. One is make nutrition tracking
that simple. Keep it super easy. Make it
natural. make it feel like you're
texting a friend versus having to sit
there and search through endless lists
of different products or, you know, at
best take a picture and cross your
fingers that you're going to get
something remotely close to what you
actually had. The other aspect is once
you make tracking really easy, how do
you take that information and build
really strong, powerful context around
the user, their flavor profile, their
interests, their habits, their hobbies,
and help steer them in the direction
that they tell you they want to go in.
And then finally, and this is what we're
excited about kicking off in the second
half of this year, is how do we take all
that information and get to a point
where we're actually connecting you with
products and different restaurants and
meals that would actually help you hit
your goals. And that's a vision that
we're very very excited about. Beyond
that, we've also discovered through our
conversations with users, we you know,
we're me and Adam uh our my co-founder
are really big believers in building in
public. Uh so we actually started we
shipped our beta less than 2 months
after incorporation and uh it was a
closed beta for roughly about 4 months
and then we shipped in February of this
year and we immediately started learning
that users don't just want to know what
calories and macros they're having but
they also want to get a rough sense of
how holistically well they're eating.
They want to know about the quality of a
food. And we realized that you know
1,000 calories could be had a million
different ways. Not all of it is equal
in terms of quality. And this is where
we developed uh the ALMA score concept
with uh our academic adviser at Harvard
University, Dr. Eric Prim. Alma score is
very simple. It's meant to be a score
out of 100 that can easily steer you
throughout the day to just have more of
the things that we know through all the
research and decades of science are
going to be fundamentally good for your
health and try to nudge you away from
some of the things that we know are not
great for you. Beyond that, let's just
start talking about building an AI,
though. I think that's what we're
ultimately all here for. So, one of the
biggest lessons we learned during the
beta is that it's really important to
rely on user feedback. I know we're all
obsessed with eval right now. We're
certainly looking at some and we've
experimented with some over the last few
months, but fundamentally nothing beats
real time in the moment feedback from
your users. So, one of my favorite
features that we built to kind of
achieve that is this little drop down
toast that pops up that says, "How did
Alma do after every single interaction
with Alma?" Uh we obviously plan to tone
that down eventually but in the early
days it's been extremely helpful for us
in guiding how we build Alma and how we
can measure accuracy and improvements
with Alma as you track it. Uh the other
thing we realized is that LLMs if you
give them an open-ended uh very large
task uh the error rates are just going
to be through the roof. It's really
really important to figure out a way to
make it so that you can constrain the
LLM to very specific tasks. And we
instead of kind of being frustrated at
that, we realized that we just need to
work with that constraint and find the
best way that we can get our desired
ultimate user experience going. And one
of the things that we executed on that
I'm really happy and proud of the team
for doing is we actually broke up the
process of how we relay the information
uh back to the user after every single
time they track with Alma track with
Alma through steps. So at every step we
send down certain aspects. So for
example for this screenshot I just said
to Alma I had a banana immediately
recognized in one of our modules that
banana was in the phrase. It extracted
that as a food item. It sent it down to
the client, the iOS app and then from
there now it's busy processing through
all the different steps including
getting involved with our USDA database
matching system so that it can actually
find the right appropriate caloric
content and send that down eventually.
This makes experience feel so much
faster for users and it's much easier
for them to interact with than just
waiting for the entire process of every
single step of our LMS to actually be uh
sent down. So, highly recommend you kind
of think about how you could do that as
well in your process. How do you break
up the steps? The other thing is, you
know, we actually last week one of our
engineers broke streaks and I've never
seen our WhatsApp community and our
intercom blow up the same way since.
Hopefully never again, but I'm okay with
it if it happens. We ended up seeing so
many users come back and say, "Don't
mess with my streaks. What happened to
my streak?" And we realized that even
though we thought of this as kind of
like a little cute feature that we were
just going to add towards the end, it's
clearly something that users really
value. And this is something that we are
planning to double down on and just
really make sure that we're having fun
while we're building Elma for us and for
our
users. Beyond that, it's really really
important that when you're building an
AI agents, we've discovered that it's
very important that you're continuing to
build context. Users get really
frustrated if they have to reiterate the
same things. Whether it's when it comes
to tracking or when it comes to actually
asking all my questions and engaging. So
we built out features like what you see
here at the top that little orb that
says about you updated whenever you
interact with Alma. We actually take
whatever piece of information if it's
novel and we add it to our knowledge
data set about you. So Alma is
constantly learning and you can view
those yourself and delete and remove
them as you wish but you can also just
continue to add to them and Alma just
gets smarter every single time you
interact with it because of that.
Finally, we realize that you can only
count on your users opening up Alma to
ask questions and engage so often. You
really want to be proactive about
reaching out to them. So, one of the
features we built that was really cool
in that regard is to actually have Alma
detect certain insights about what
you're eating and surface things you
might not know about. For example, I
didn't discover that blueberries are
really, really good for certain things
like if you pair it with dark chocolate,
it's actually increases the absorption
of vitamin C. And there's a whole bunch
of different things that I've learned
through my engagement with Alma
throughout throughout it just kind of
reaching out, pinging me, and letting me
know certain things about my food that I
didn't know about. So, it's feels like
this constant process of learning about
food, but in a bite-sized format, fun,
not intended. The other thing what we
learned, this was something I obsessed
about a lot early on in the days of
building Alma is to think through, you
know, which modality is going to be the
winning one. You know, I personally love
voice. I love talking to Alma. I just
turn it on at the end of the day if I'm
busy. And I'll just track, you know,
I'll just track my lunch, breakfast, and
dinner all in one shot in under 10
seconds. It used to take me minutes and
feel like this really laborious exercise
is dreaded previously. And now it's that
simple with voice. But I learned from
engaging with our users and seeing how
they track the Alma that they actually
love the multimodality. So I've often
heard this from our users that they like
the fact that Alma makes it really easy
to talk to, to take a photo, or to text
and depending on the context. So instead
of really being bullish on one specific
modality, I've learned that you really
want to provide your users with as many
different modalities that make sense for
them. In terms of looking forward and
where we think the space is going, what
we're doubling down in Alma is it's
really comes down to these three key
learnings from our experience. One is
brand and design count for a lot. code
is becoming a commodity and no matter
how great your code is, if you don't
have a product that's really user
centric and has a design that's visually
appealing, it's going to be extremely
hard for you to stand out. So, we're
doubling down on that. It's in our DNA.
My co-founder Adam is absolutely focused
on it and I trust them fully in it. And
then it's really an important part of
how we kind of think about building over
time. And then second pillar is, you
know, really trust and partnerships. You
earn your users's trust, especially when
you're new, by seeing who they trust and
partnering with them if there is an
aligned mission. So, we're really
focusing on that right now. We
constantly ask our users where do they
get their information from, who do they
trust, and we try to focus on seeing how
we can bring some of those into the mix
and partner with them in a win-win type
of format. And then finally, community
and new data is something that we're
really uh shifting our focus towards now
as well. We're realizing that as our
community grows, there's so many
interesting things that people want to
learn about how others are eating. It's
just kind of a very curious aspect of
food consumption. Like food is generally
something that you people like to have
in company and people like to talk about
food. So people are very curious, you
know, how else how other Alma members
eat and how could they potentially learn
from them or adopt some of their habits.
So we're doubling down on features like
that. And you know, I think the reality
is most of the LLM foundation model
companies and some of the bigger players
are hoovering up data. So if there's
something online that you're scraping
and you're getting access to, there's a
high chance that they already done that.
So you really want to think about how
can you leverage your users and members
to create net new data that's actually
valuable and interesting. And this is
something that we're doubling down on as
well. So I wish you all the best in this
journey. We're just getting started at
Alma and if you want to give it a shot
and try it out, just give it a go. And
just as a thank you for taking the time
to listen to this presentation, I wanted
to throw you a little promo code here.
Use Alma fam, ship it to Alma. I hope to
see you in the Alma WhatsApp community
soon. Take care.